[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMEET JANI: When marketing
asked us to give a talk,
Christiaan, Dale,
and I said, only
if we can be the last
session on the last day.
Thank you marketing.
No, but you obviously, clearly
are committed to security.
And so we have, I think, a
very interesting talk here.
Just out of curiosity,
how many of you
have heard of BeyondCorp,
Google's BeyondCorp's story?
OK, there's some hands.
For those of you who haven't--
I'm sorry?
You wouldn't come otherwise?
That's how good the story is.
Just for those of
you who haven't heard
of BeyondCorp, just a brief--
and we'll get into the
details here in a minute.
This is a model,
a security posture
that Google started
going through
about five to seven years
ago, where we decided
that the traditional
model of security
doesn't work for Google
anymore, or in any company
where the employees are
scattered all over the world.
VPN's are really not the way to
answer those questions anymore.
And so we'll talk
about those details.
I'm Ameet, Christiaan
will come up shortly,
and then we have
Dale from Vendasta
who is going to give
us a lot of detail
into what those guys
did around the vision
and how some of our tooling
helps them get there.
So that's in fact what
we're talking about today.
So I will quickly review
the BeyondCorp stuff.
We want to talk about
some of the new products
we've launched that
would help customers
get this vision delivered.
So we'll talk about the
Identity-Aware Proxy,
which you may have heard
yesterday Urs talk about.
And then Christiaan will talk
through the Security Key.
And then we want to
leave a lot of time
here for Dale to come up.
I think that he has a really
interesting story about how
Vendasta went
through their change
in security
architecture, how they
started implementing all this.
And he likes questions.
And he asked me
explicitly to tell you
to ask him lots of questions.
So let's get started.
I wanted to quickly review
what BeyondCorp really means
and what it means for
you, the enterprise.
We think of this as really
Context-Aware secure access.
So as we dive into that, let
me start with a little bit of--
and this is the way
that Google did it.
I think this is the way
a lot of our customers
are going through
this model now.
The traditional
model of security
is what we call the
Walled Garden approach.
You have an employee who has to
access exciting and interesting
information and applications.
We make them go through a VPN.
No matter where
they sit, we make
them go through this tiresome,
cumbersome high-latency VPN,
and then they can get access
to all their applications.
That model starts to break down,
of course, as all of you know,
when you start to introduce
new users and new devices.
So you introduce a contractor,
who is not necessarily
a corporate employee,
and potentially
users that are coming
out on mobile devices.
Getting to the applications
becomes harder and harder
in that model.
And when you do
extend that model
to fit for contractors
and mobile devices,
you find you have
unintended consequences.
Here, we have a contractor who
is supposed to be accessing
the CRM system, but what
they're-- in essence,
you're allowing them
to access everything,
including the ERP system.
So the Walled Garden gets
breached in this model.
The evolution of what
we're going through now
even more complicates
this model.
So you're now taking these
applications that at least used
to be behind a
VPN, and now you're
putting them in a Cloud--
hopefully our Cloud, since
you're here, but many of you
are putting them in many Clouds.
And so now the security
model and access model
starts to really break down
on how this world works.
And then finally,
what you've moved--
as some of our leading
customers are starting to do--
is start to move identity
into the cloud as well.
So there's no more
on-prem AD or it's
becoming a secondary thing.
Well, really, now, identity
lives in the Cloud as well.
So everything, in essence,
is on the internet.
You're in multiple places
with multiple applications.
Securing access to
all of this world
becomes very, very complicated.
And so what that does
is, it introduces
a whole set of new risk.
There's many, many
here, but I wanted
to highlight some
of the key ones.
And I think this is
the key takeaway slide.
There are lots of things that we
start to introduce as problems.
And your vendors or you need
to start introducing solutions
for these problems.
So the first one, let's start--
I mean, we can start
at the very beginning--
the employee,
themselves, are they
really who they say they are?
Are they using the
right credentials
or has someone stolen
those credentials?
You think OTP's are
safe, but those are just
bearer tokens in
essence, so somebody
can come steal that
and use that as well.
So now you have to
worry, is this the user
that they say they are?
Even if the user is
who they say they are,
if they're using a device
that's compromised,
they're using a personal device
that has a lot of malware
on it, what you're finding is
that whatever data is accessed,
the device has access
to, is now stolen data.
And we'll talk about this
in a bit more detail.
I think a big and
complicated part of all this
is, of course, the network.
One is, is your
network encrypted?
Is there a passive
listener on there?
Is there a man in the middle
that's happening here?
Can your network
handle a Dos attack?
Can it handle the load
that needs to be there?
You have uptown requirements.
The network need to be able
to handle all of these things.
And then, as we've talked
about, as you move to the Cloud,
the new model is, who can
see these applications?
Think about all the legacy,
lift-and-shift applications
that you're moving to the Cloud.
They used to be safe
behind the walls of a VPN.
When you move them to the
Cloud, these legacy systems,
they don't have
traditional access models.
And now they're on the Cloud.
Are they accessible by anybody?
And even if it's not a
lift-and-shift application,
applications that are
custom-built for the web--
and actually, Dale
has a good point,
so I'm not going to
steal its thunder.
But you are very good
at application logic.
Your developer's very
good at application logic.
Is security necessarily
a strong point
for what that person does?
And so we need to provide tools
and things in that domain.
So in essence, this is
a high-level overview
of where things
start to go wrong.
And installing it,
then, the right--
OK, good.
So then what you're
starting to see is--
let's get concrete about the
things that I've talked about,
like phishing and--
I'll steal Christiaan's
thunder here-- phishing
becomes one of the
largest attack vectors
against your organization.
Somebody can either just fake
a website for your employee
to go to and enter their
credentials and that's it,
or someone steals a token
or cookie from your browser.
All it takes is for
that token to be gone.
It's a bearer token
in essence now,
and your account is phished.
Everyone can access as you.
The second one is malware.
We see it in a lot
of our customers.
They're saying, oh,
I had a backdoor
I didn't even know about.
Information just
started leaking around.
The man-in-the-middle--
think of an example--
actually, we had a customer
that actually had this problem.
During Heartbleed,
somebody used Heartbleed
to get search from a
supposedly protected server.
Even though the company
thought the traffic was all
encrypted in HTTPs, the
key is out there now.
People are listening
man-in-the-middle of those
attacks.
Or all of you know
companies that
have suffered
through Dos attacks
and have really suffered
through all those things.
The access policy-- access
policy is, in some points,
a choke point.
You can start to really
enforce access at these thing.
And we'll talk about what
we can do with proxies.
And of course, on
the application side,
it's very clear that you can
have cross-site scripting
attacks, you can have buffer
overflows, all these types
of things that just end
up leaking information out
into the world.
And so there are solutions
to these problems.
And there are lots of
players in this space,
but the vendors you go
with need to provide
those kinds of solutions.
You have to have some sort
of phishing-resistant auth,
and we have a Security Key
solution, which Christiaan
will talk to in a moment here.
But the idea should be that even
if your username and password
gets compromised, there
are other factors,
other second factors,
that are not compromisable
and they'll protect access
to your applications.
Device management
is another key area
where there's a lot of
opportunity for protection
here, in two ways, if
you think about it.
One is in the configuration
of your device.
And I'm enforcing
that anti-virus
needs to be on this device.
I need to make sure that
anti-virus is there,
for example, or in the
state of the device.
Even if everything seems
like it's set properly,
is there a screen lock enabled?
Is it in the right IP address?
Those are the kinds
of things where
you need to be able
to say, even if it's
the right person on a
corporate-issued device,
is the device in a good
state before I allow access?
The other part of this
layered cake, if you will,
is this idea that you
have well-configured TLS.
Managing the search for all
of the TLS and everything
is a hard job.
And a lot of DevOps
people are focused
on keeping everything
up, but not
necessarily in
managing these certs,
protecting against DoS
attacks, and things like that.
That needs to be--
we need to make sure that we
offer those solutions right out
of the box for you.
To me, the most interesting
part of this talk,
because it's one of
the products I work on,
is this idea that you have
a proxy choke point that
controls access.
You can do a lot of
things at this layer.
The first thing
that you can do is,
you can start to take the
context of the request.
Is it coming from
the right IP address?
Is it coming from a safe device?
Was the user strong
authed in all of this?
And say, yes, all of
these boxes check.
Let's allow access
to go on here.
But the proxy also
does other things.
It says, unlike a VPN model
in the old world, you can say,
now you can create more
fine-grained access
control over these places.
The ERP app is out-of-bounds
for me, the CRM app isn't.
You can start to set those
types of access policies
at this proxy.
And then, of course, you
should always continuously
be doing scans of
your applications
that are running in
the Cloud, making sure
that there's no security
vulnerabilities or anything
that's gone wild out there.
And so we envision a world
where an administrator
or a developer, even, can
start to set very simplified
policies that have very
powerful consequences.
An example of that is, for
access to my ERP application,
I only want members of my
finance group to access this.
No setting up VPNs, no
making sure everybody's
at the right place.
Only members of my finance team
should be able to have access.
They should only be
coming from corp devices.
They should only be coming
from in [INAUDIBLE] network
or from the right geographies.
I want to make sure they
are who they say they are,
and I want to make
sure that that's
coming across a secure network.
Those are very key policies
that I want to set.
They should be check,
check, check, check.
And you should be getting
that out of the box.
Google Cloud, especially
after the announcements
we made yesterday, if any
of you saw Urs's talk,
starts to offer a lot of
solutions in this space.
We introduced the
identity where proxy, this
is how we want to control
access to applications
by users' identities from
well-managed devices.
Watch the things
that we're going
to start to be doing here.
We have an MDM solution already.
We're going to offer richer
solutions coming out shortly.
From certain
geographies, we want
to make sure you can
start to set policies that
say corp network,
not corp network,
not from sanctioned countries,
from sanctioned countries,
whatever it happens to be.
We also want you to be able
to use Security Key to be--
I know I'm not supposed to use
the word unphishable-- but very
phishing-resistant in
accessing these applications.
And the load balancer starts
to provide a lot of things.
It provides your
TLS terminations.
You want to be able to be
hardened against these attacks.
We offer solutions
in these spaces.
So a lot of these things
we already provide here.
You see the green
and white boxes.
What we're now introducing
today, or actually yesterday,
are two new parts of this
chain, which we think
gives you full coverage
from end to end.
And it's not that the
journey ever ends,
but now we think we have
a lot of the boxes checked
in total security.
First is Security
Key enforcement,
and the second is
Identity-Aware Proxy.
And so we'll talk about
these two products briefly,
and then we'll let Dale
come up on afterwards
and talk through how
these things become
actually useful in the wild.
So I'll start with the
Identity-Aware Proxy
and then hand it
over to Christiaan.
We call it IAP for
its loving name, which
is this part of the cycle.
IAP, actually, the
idea is very simple,
but the value it provides
is actually quite huge here.
What we want to do is, we
want to give administrators
and developers a way
of configuring access
controls by the people who
are supposed to get access
to those applications.
You set users, you
set the groups,
you set the application that
it's supposed to reach to.
And IAP enforces
that access control.
And the value here
is that the devs
can focus on the logic
of their applications.
We take care of all the other
things that go along and around
the security of that.
And the administrator has
full control in that world.
And so the experience is
actually very simplified here.
The administrator comes in--
this is not actual
policy syntax,
but I wanted to
use it to highlight
how things work here--
you specify very clearly,
members of the finance team
can access my ERP application.
That's it, it's
as simple as that.
And if any of you have
seen the UI, you can see,
it's actually literally where
you pick your application back
in, you click the slider to
activate, add your users,
and you're up and running.
It's that quick.
So then the next day, the
user actually comes along.
Here comes Sarah.
She's a member of the finance
group, we can validate that.
Actually, let me go back.
And she is, in fact,
who she says she is.
If we don't know who she
is, we [INAUDIBLE] send
her back to your SSE
or IDP to validate,
or if it's a Google
identity, we can send her
to the Google Identity system.
She validates who she is.
Once IAP does that check and
says, yes, this is, in fact,
Sarah, yes, she actually
belongs to the IAP--
she actually belongs
to the finance team,
the next thing to do
is, does she get access?
IAP makes that check
and says, yes, Sarah
does, in fact, get access
to the ERP application.
And so she's in
and she's running,
and her life should go on
very smoothly and easily.
And we avoid the unintended
access consequence, which
is to say, but she
hasn't been specified
to access the CRM application,
so she doesn't get access
to the CRM application.
It's as simple as that.
And so that is,
in essence, how we
want to deliver IAP as a first
step of the BeyondCorp vision
to a lot of our customers
that are running in the Cloud.
And I think, as the
second part of that,
Christiaan will come up
and talk about strong auth.
CHRISTIAAN BRAND:
Hello, can you hear me?
I'm on?
Yep.
Hi.
Hi everyone, I'm
Christiaan Brand.
Thanks Ameet.
I'm a product manager
on the team at Google
responsible for
identity and security.
And over the next
couple of minutes,
I really want to be focusing
on secure user authentication--
that's the green part there--
and how we can make sure
that we're providing access
in this model to
the rightful user.
So phishing-- and I'm sure you
all know exactly what phishing
is, but just to recap briefly--
phishing, an attack where
a bad guy tricks a user
into revealing their sensitive
credentials, such as a user
name and a password,
to the wrong website,
accounted for 2/3 of
the security incidents
in 2015, according to a
Verizon data breach report.
Now, other than
phishing, there is also
other types of compromises--
passwords get
compromised through reuse
and interception--
but the industry has a
solution to this problem.
The industry solution is
multi-factor authentication.
But the problem is that most of
the multi-factor authentication
solutions today rely on just
another form of a password,
the one-time password.
And these really are
just as trivially
easy to phish as the
user's standard password.
And it doesn't really
provide adequate protection
for high-value accounts.
So Google's research
have also shown that even
with all the user education
going on and trying
to warn users against phishing
attacks and educate them,
users will still fall for
sophisticated phishing scams
about half of the time.
So this really is a
systemic industry problem.
So the mechanism
we use at Google
to achieve secure and
phishing-resistant logins
is based on a tiny
piece of hardware
we call the Security Key.
You can see that on the right.
So Security Keys form the
basis of all authentication
at Google.
And if you use Google as
your identity provider,
you can also benefit from
this same advanced protection.
So let's briefly take
a couple of moments
here and go through how Security
Keys really work and achieve
this elevated level of
protection against phishing.
So typically, if we look at
what we're presenting here,
there is a user,
the user is trying
to get access to a server.
What normally happens in
single-factor authentication
world, a password gets sent
from the left to the right,
and that provides the user
access to the resource,
pretty simple.
So let's take a look at
these next few slides.
So we see something
on the screen here,
and I'm going to show
you something else now.
What changed?
Does anyone have an idea what
changed between these two
slides?
So let me call that out.
The URL bar, that's
phishing, right?
So a user thinks they're
on exactly the right site,
they're going to input
their credentials,
but actually, they're not
really on the rightful website.
And because users,
we're trained to look
at the URL bar and
things like that,
but it's a lot of
cognitive load for users.
And most of the
time, they actually--
like we said with our
research as proven--
about half of the
time, users actually
don't check for all these
little details on the pages.
And they still actually
end up in these traps
that a malicious bad
guy set for them,
and they give away credentials
to some phishing website.
Now, one of the questions
is, how did they
get to this page
in the first place?
They didn't just mistype.
And I'll show that in
a second, you're right.
So typically, let's just talk
through the phishing attack,
pretty simple.
User enters password,
password goes to bad guy,
bad guy sends password
to rightful server,
and bad guy's logged in,
pretty straightforward.
So let's look at the next
slide and how the user actually
gets to this bad website
in the first place.
Well, normally,
that's the model.
Someone get sent
an email, the email
looks like it's from
the right party.
The email might say
something like, hey, you
need to immediately change your
password because someone tried
to log in to your account.
The user would
click on the link,
unknowingly going to a phishing
website, because there is--
it's hard for the user to figure
out whether this email really
came from a trusted source.
And there's other
protections, of course,
that's in place there.
But at the bare basic
level, users [INAUDIBLE]
still fall for these attacks.
And that's what we see.
Like I said, about 2/3
of incidents in 2015
was as a result of
this kind of attack.
So we really need to do
something to try and protect.
So let's now look at
Security Keys very briefly.
So what we have is a
user, here on the left.
The user is trying to
sign in to a website.
But in addition to only
sending the password,
something else happens here.
The user typically
has a Security Key.
Security Keys come in various
different form factors.
We have USB-based Security Keys,
we've had them for a while.
We now also have
Security Keys that
can be attached over NFC,
near-field communication,
and Bluetooth, Bluetooth
Low Energy, or BLE.
So this Security Key
on the left-hand side
is with the user when
they try to sign in,
but this Security Key also
contain a cryptographic key.
It contains a
unique, private key.
And there is an associated
key at the server
called the public key.
And this kind of key
pair got generated
at some point in the past
when the user registered
their access for this
specific service.
When their password
was set up, they also
registered their
Security Key, which
created these two key pairs.
And the public key got
sent to the server,
and the private key got
generated and stored
on the token.
So what happens now, when
the user tries to sign in,
there is actually a
password that goes down.
Yes, that's your first factor.
But there's also an
additional signed--
very important--
cryptographic assertion
that goes from the
device to the server.
And this cryptographic
assertion has three
very important components.
So the first one is the
promise that the user
was physically present.
And the way we promise
that is by simply, actually
allowing the user
to only generate
the insertion of the device
to only generate the insertion
when the button was
clicked on the token.
So you'll see, with
these Security Keys,
they normally have a
capacitive touch or resistive
touch, or a physical button
that need to be pressed.
So at the point in time
where you want to sign in,
you need to physically
press this button.
So that's the
promise, that a user
was present at the time
of log in at the machine.
There's a server challenge.
And this is just part of
the usual crypto response
to protect against
replay attacks.
So the server sends a
challenge to the device,
and then the token responds back
with that specific challenge,
so in the response.
But that's not the
most important.
The most important part
of this, and the thing
that really protects the user
against phishing at this point,
is that third line there
that we call the origin.
So what happens is, when the
user is on a specific website
on the left-hand side here,
or they're trying to access
a certain service, the
URI and the specific eTLD,
or the top-level
domain, normally +1,
in the case of the
protocol that I have here,
that's specified by
the specific request.
But when the user is on
a website, that website,
for lack of a better term,
that they're on actually
gets incorporated in
the digital signature
that goes back to the server.
So whatever the user is
on on the left-hand side
gets incorporated
into the signature
and sent to the server.
So if the user is on the
rightful Google website,
the Google server on
the right-hand side
will look at the signature and
say, yep, that's what I expect.
I expected the user to be
on this specific website.
That's what the signature
presented to me,
so I'll allow the
user to sign in.
So let's look at
a phishing attack
and how the Security
Key, in this case,
defeat the phishing attack
that we saw a little earlier.
So we have the same example.
We've got the Security
Key on the left,
we have the corresponding
public key on the right.
We have the user
trying to sign in.
There is a phishing
guy in the middle.
User is the wrong
URL, as we can see.
So what happens is, we send
the password, as per normal,
over to the bad guy.
The bad guy presents the
crypto challenge to the user.
The user clicks the button
on their Security Key,
a assertion gets generated.
And the assertion that the
bad guy gets at this point
is obviously an assertion
for the wrong website.
So when the bad guy
sends that assertion back
to the rightful relying
party or the server--
Google, in this case--
Google will look
at that and say,
hey, I don't expect this origin
to be goggle.com, I'm Google.
And at that point in time, they
will simply reject the login.
So it's really, actually
pretty straightforward
if you break it up like this.
But the point is, the bad guy
in the middle cannot tamper with
that message block that
gets sent from the client
to the server because it's
digitally signed using this
private key that was generated
out of band previously.
So that's the protocol
in general, so pretty
straightforward, but
really pretty powerful.
So another question is, how does
this technology apply to you?
Well, we launched something
we call Security Key
Enforcement about a month ago.
We spoke about it
earlier as well.
And this really allows
you, as an administrator,
to enforce the use of Security
Keys on certain groups of users
or in certain
organizational units.
And by enforcing
Security Keys, you
make it really hard for bad
guys to trick your users
into falling for phishing scams,
because even if the user is
on a website that
there shouldn't be on,
the Security Key will
generate the signature
that your server will be
able to detect as fraudulent.
And the other thing is,
Security Keys, of course,
now supported on both
desktop and mobile.
We've had Security Key
support for a while at Google.
It was mainly around
USB, but we now also
have support on
Android and iOS devices
using NFC and Bluetooth
protocols there.
Then, turning it on
for a subset of users
is really straightforward.
Typically, it's a
one-click event.
Where you configure
two-step verification,
you now have the
option to say, hey,
I want only Secure Keys
on these groups of users.
And at that point,
it'll be enforced.
And all the other controls
that goes together with this--
onboarding users, taking
them through the onboarding
process--
that's all part and parcel
of this one-click event.
So as a last slide here,
Stripe, one of our customers,
has rolled out Security
Key enforcement
to all of their users.
And they really believe
that this is the perfect way
to balance ease of use
with increased account
security across both
desktop and mobile devices.
So in summary, if you're
worried about phishing,
implement Security
Key enforcement.
And if you want controlled
access to applications
from the internet, implement
Identity-Aware Proxy.
And with that, let me hand
you over to Dale from Vendasta
to talk about their
implementation.
Thank you.
DALE HOPKINS: Thank you.
So hopefully, these slide
transitions work all right.
So what I'm going
to start off with
is the obligatory
marketing slide,
but I think it's actually
pretty relevant, in this case,
to understand who
our customers are.
And so the way we
describe our business
is, we strive to be the
number-one platform for selling
digital solutions to small
business or local business.
And so if you want
to think of who
is the end user of our
software, in a lot of cases,
it's a small business.
And so this is not necessarily
the high-value target,
but it is often, also,
sometimes a person
that's not super
familiar with digital,
because one of the things
we're helping these people with
is basically a digital
transformation for them,
to use the word that
I guess we use here.
What we're talking
about is, these guys
used to buy Yellow Page ads.
They used to buy all these
traditional media and things
like that.
And they're looking for, I
want customers, basically,
in my store.
Or even better, some
of them want customers
on a website they don't have.
So we essentially help
to provide those tools
to small business.
And the way we do
that is, 85% of them
purchase from an
actual, physical person
that comes and calls on them.
So we do this through resellers.
So we have 1,700 brands that
actually have salespeople
that represent our
software as their brand
and then sell this
to small business.
And so for us, security, we
consider it pretty important.
And we consider
security, actually,
as one of those features,
that it's like performance
in a lot of ways, in that
you don't really know its a
problem until you don't
have it, and then you
realize that you actually did
want performance or security.
But unlike performance, if
you don't deliver on security,
it's pretty hard to
actually regain trust.
Because if you
have a slow website
and you improve the performance,
I mean, that's cool,
your users are
probably OK with that.
But if you lose all their data
or they use their bank password
to log in to your website and
you lost it, that's a big deal.
And so, I guess,
looking at this,
when we read the
BeyondCorp paper,
there's a couple of
things that we thought
were pretty striking on it.
And it actually put--
you guys all said you'd heard
of the BeyondCorp paper,
how many of you have actually
read the BeyondCorp paper?
So I don't see a
ton of hands, so I
thought I would give
a couple of key pieces
to the BeyondCorp paper.
And I know that we
talked earlier--
Ameet was saying we wanted to
change a little bit about VPNs.
And I mean, a lot of
people are thinking,
we're switching to Clouds,
so VPNs are too complicated,
and so that's why we
don't want to use VPNs.
And I think that, I mean, we're
actually missing the point,
if that's what you're thinking.
In terms of VPNs, the real
issue is that on a VPN,
it's more of a traditional,
hard candy approach,
I think they call it.
And so the idea is, once
you're on the network,
you have access to everything.
And so really, what
we're seeing here
is, if your application
design involves a VPN,
and it's for a new
application, you're
probably thinking
about it wrong,
because what you're
basically saying
is that I want to protect
access to my entire application,
and as long as I can do that,
I'm going to be OK on security.
And the way that I think that--
it's not in the
BeyondCorp paper,
but it was something I actually
heard at DockerCon last year.
I don't remember the
speaker to give him credit,
but what he said
is that if you're
thinking about
preventing hackers,
you probably have
already lost the game.
Really, the answer you want
to do is, when you get hacked,
you want to minimize
the damage, and you
want to make sure that other
things don't get hacked.
Because again,
especially for us,
in this picture that
Ameet was showing before,
I don't have control
over their devices.
over a lot of stuff,
so my goal is to actually make
it so that if one of my users
does actually get attacked,
they don't get access
to other user's data.
So we can minimize
damage in that way.
And then, the other
part is to make it
harder, because again, it is
unlikely that a nation state is
choosing to attack one of
our small business customers
who runs a hardware
shop in Delaware
to access his information about
his advertising or website.
But at the same
time, I don't want
to trivialize this
security problem either
because it still is important.
And so for this,
what we talk about
is essentially a service proxy.
And this is--
Ameet was talking a little bit
about this earlier in terms of,
this is--
I mean, we simplified
a little bit
in terms of saying
that this is just IAP,
and I'll get into
that in a second.
But as an example, on
our Cloud that we run,
our entire infrastructure
is on Google Cloud.
So I don't have an
on-premise deployment,
and I don't have another Cloud.
So those are not the
reasons for me switching
to this sort of deployment.
I control access to
all of my microservices
and my deployments
through a service proxy.
So that actually means
that all of my services
are publicly accessible.
And so we don't have a VPN,
we don't have special networks
and things like that.
They're all accessible this way.
And so what I do is, I use the
multi-factor authentication,
specifically for access to GCP.
And I do actually
use service accounts,
and I encrypt my traffic
between all of my microservices.
How many of you here have
a microservice architecture
that you guys run?
We got a few hands.
So quite of you
probably have a--
I guess, so a show of hands,
how many people, then,
have a monolith that they run?
OK.
So then, we've got about
half the people here
that run software.
But anyways, in either
case, what you have is,
you essentially--
even in a monolith,
it's likely that you have
segments of your code
that you're exposing.
Maybe not as a--
maybe you could be
pedantic and you
don't want to call
it a microservice,
but it is a separate
piece of code.
What we try to think
of is that encrypting
between those systems is
actually really important,
and trying to make sure
that you have identities
and everything else
like that, again,
because then if your
software, like a vulnerability
or somebody gains access that
they shouldn't, they can't just
sit there and browse
your whole network
and see all your traffic.
And so for us, the
way we do that is,
we just make it
publicly accessible.
And so it's pretty--
it makes everybody, all the
engineers and everybody,
think about, wait a minute,
this is a public-facing service,
I obviously have
to encrypt things,
I obviously need identity, and I
can't trust that this is a VPN.
So actually, it leads to
some better practices.
And so what we
actually said is--
how many of you would
consider yourselves
that you're fairly well-versed,
like understanding security?
And then, is there anybody
in the audience here
that sells security
as their product?
Like two other vendors.
So the thing that we look
at is, we don't do that.
And so for us, if you're
a vendor of security,
the solution I'm talking
about, potentially, this
is something that
you don't necessarily
want to do what
I'm talking about.
But what I say is, I'm going
to delegate identity to Google.
It's a really hard problem.
And when Christiaan was up here,
you hear him talking about,
we've got Special Keys of
hardware, we've got signing,
we're thinking about pshishing.
And then I'm sitting
in the audience,
and I'm like, this
sounds great, but what
happens if somebody hacks DNS?
I don't know.
These are the kind
of questions that I
don't want to have my engineers
really worrying about.
And so what we actually do
is, we delegate our security
to Google.
And again, I don't delegate
all of my security.
So then, what it becomes is, I
have to think about security.
I do consider you need
to be, at some level,
an expert on security
to understand,
what is Google doing and
am I comfortable with that,
and making sure that, I mean,
I'm covering the other stuff
that Google doesn't.
And so in terms of the
security, the words
that I enjoy that Google gave
out-- and I don't think it's
fair to give them
credit for the naming--
but we finally switched
from authentication
and authorization to identity
and access management.
I'm suspecting it's
one of the other Cloud
vendors that came up with that.
But I think the idea is, it's
a really good distinction,
because they don't
both start with "off,"
and so it makes it
easier to actually
have a conversation
because you don't
have that cognitive load of,
which one are we talking about?
So I delegate identity to
Google because it's probably
the hardest part.
And in terms of
your security, it's
one of the most
important pieces,
because if I have a really great
access management system that's
very good at controlling whether
Ameet has access to documents
or whether I have
access to documents,
but the system actually has a
really hard time determining
whether it's me or
Ameet accessing it,
my security's a waste of time.
So for us, we
think that identity
is one of the core parts, that
just because you get it right
doesn't mean you're secure,
but if you get it wrong,
you're pretty much not secure.
And so we consider
that as something we
choose Google as
a partner for this
to make these
things more secure.
And so in terms of what we also
do is, at this point, my users,
my small businesses,
they log in to my system,
so I've got usernames
and passwords.
And so what we're
doing is, we're
switching to single sign-on.
And so that means--
everybody here has probably
used that, in terms of--
single sign-on is one of those
terms that gets thrown around
and oftentimes abused,
but what it actually--
I think the term, if you look
it up in its original version,
what it's talking about
is, sign-in with Gmail
would be an easy way
to think about it,
or sign-in with Facebook,
or sign-in with GitHub,
or something like that.
What you're
essentially saying is
that I'm going to sign
on with one provider
and I'm going to get access
to multiple services.
So the good part in this
is that, again, we're
trusting Google to manage all
that extra work of checking
devices, checking Security
Keys, checking passwords.
And then eventually,
at the end, when
the request comes in, we say,
is this guy who he says he is?
And Google says, yeah,
I'm pretty confident this
is who he says he is.
Now, there's a few issues
that we can talk about this.
I would like to have some
more, because right now,
what we have is-- how many
of you guys use G Suite?
So we've got a few people here.
How many of you guys use
two-factor with your G Suite?
So we've got a few
people that do.
One of the things that
you'll find that G Suite does
for us right now, which
is kind of interesting,
is it assigns the level of trust
required to an actual user.
And so what it's
going to say is, hey,
Dale is a guy who
has access to quite
a few top-secret
documents, and so we want
to make sure he has two-factor.
But then, what
that actually means
for me is, now, when I want
to SSO into Stack Overflow,
I need two-factor.
And so one of the
things we would like
is the ability to say, I
can, as an application,
say what level of
trust I care about.
And that could be either
at an application level,
like IAP talks about,
or even within an app.
Because you could
imagine, on Google Docs,
it's frustrating if I have to
have Security Keys and a bunch
of other stuff when I want
to read the Social Committee
meeting minutes.
And the same level of trust is
required for other documents.
So some of that stuff,
I think, there's
some room to move forward,
specifically around making
it easier for these users.
And so when I was talking
earlier about the service
proxy, which is that
IAP, one of the things
that's important to
see is that we actually
use a couple pieces here.
But a load balancer is obviously
another important component
if your service has more
than one computer, or VM,
or container, or whatever
that's going to be serving it.
And so a Layer 7 load
balancer plus IAP
is actually, in terms of if
you're reading the BeyondCorp
paper, that's how we
view what the service
proxy in that picture is.
And this is what we use
in front of basically
all of our services on
Kubernetes that we run in GKE.
And so this is
what's implementing
that particular piece.
And I think I've got a beautiful
animation here that the Google
marketing guys put together.
This is what we were talking
about earlier, and then boom,
it breaks that first
piece up into two.
You guys have all probably
used the Layer 7 load balancer.
It's really not that bad.
And I mean, when Ameet
comes up here and shows
that you just type in a policy
and it works out pretty well,
this stuff, it is pretty
easy to get started with
and add some pretty powerful
rules to add this security.
And then, what
Cloud Endpoints does
for us is, we implement our
microservices using gRPC.
And what you'll find is
that a lot of our customers
do not like or use gRPC.
And for us, we don't
really want to have to--
we don't have to lower our
performance or our expectations
of our own APIs by implementing
them all as JSON REST.
And so what we do is,
we use Cloud Endpoints
to provide a JSON gateway.
It provides monitoring.
There's a lot of
great functionally
the Cloud Endpoints provides,
and it's just a sidecar
running along with our pods.
And so that's what
we offer there.
And so then, every single
one of the requests
that's coming in here, we've got
an identity associated with it.
We've got Cloud
Endpoints here to manage
some of the monitoring
and the other things.
And then our applications are
left to manage the access.
And so, again, we have a
course-grain level from IAP,
but again, we can implement
our own specific access
requirements at
the service levels.
I guess, one of the things
we look at here-- sorry,
I guess I've got the
beautiful thing down here.
We use these keys, again, to
protect accounts in our office.
As an example, I have access
to delete GCP projects,
and so for us, we
consider it important
that I do use two-factor.
Some of the stuff that I think
we were talking about earlier
with Security Keys, this is
great that they're-- and I know
a lot of people will say,
you can't say the words
unphishable, which
I think is fair.
I think we get into things
like the Security Keys
actually on these guys
in the U2F standard.
They actually support
client certs in the way
that we were talking
about signing there,
but you can actually
get down to a TLS level
and do some of
those things, too.
So it's pretty cool what
some of these things support.
And it's important
to our business,
because again, it's
not the small business
that I have to necessarily
protect at this level,
but it's basically the
people at my office
that I need to make sure
this sort of stuff happens.
But obviously, that only
works if I can actually
delegate log-in into my
system for my users to Google.
And so we've already done this.
So what this means is, if you're
a user in any of my systems
that has access to
administrative functionality,
we actually require you to have
both the log-in into our system
and a Google login.
And so what it means is
that I can manage admin
access to my entire
application through G Suite,
because I can just disable
a G Suite account, and all
of a sudden, now
you have no access
to any more of the
admin functions.
And then, in terms
of what we actually
see as really exciting,
is our ability
to throw in this second factor.
And the one thing that we lack
right now as a part of this
is when I get an identity,
I have no ability to say,
hey, does this identity
have two-factor on it?
So its up to me to
make sure that I've
implemented two-factor on my
organization, and the functions
that I want to be
two-factor-protected,
that I've coordinated that.
It would be really nice
if, when an identity came
in, Google could
say, hey, here's
the level of trust
associated with this,
so I didn't have to make
sure that I've got it
right in two different places.
And so there's a whole bunch of
different things that I think--
I want to summarize
a couple, I want
to make sure I didn't
miss any of them here--
but the idea of using
client certs, specifically
to simplify.
I think people have talked
about, at one of the talks
I was at, it was, what version
of the best practice for OAuth
should we be following?
And in some ways, for
us, service to service is
simplified if you just use
client-based certs in terms
of, I have a client cert
that exists on one of these--
either it's protected
in my service
if it's a back-end
service, or maybe it's
on my UB key or
something like that.
It's something that
we would really like,
and it's not something
that's supported
right now, in terms of if you're
using a Layer 7 load balancer.
So you can't actually do that
for some of these things.
And then the other
thing that bothers
us is, gRPC is not supported
right now on the Layer 7 load
balancer.
So while the picture up here
is showing a Layer 7 load
balancer, we use that
for our JSON gateways.
And the gRPC stuff goes through
a Layer 4 load balancer.
So that kind of stuff is
something that we end up
having to compromise in there.
And then, I guess some
of the other stuff
is, we would like
to see this ability
to do more metadata
about the identity,
because right now,
it's just, I get
an email address, basically,
is what I get for an identity.
And it would be nice
to support things,
like we said, the metadata
about the level of trust,
or even the case of,
again, I will call it
a stacked identity, which
is, I'm microservice one,
and I want to do this
work on behalf of Dale,
and I actually have both of
those pieces of information
that could be helpful.
And so those are
some of the things
that I'm looking at in
terms of our organization.
And so again, what
you're going to find
is that the conclusions
are actually
very similar that we
came to that Ameet
talked about earlier--
or was it Christiaan?
I think it was Christiaan that
actually summarized it up.
We've implemented Security
Key enforcement internally,
and we've implemented
Identity-Aware Proxy.
And then what we've
specifically done
is, we've moved to SSO for all
of our identity internally.
And our goal is,
over the coming year,
to start to roll more of that
out to our customers by adding
support for SSO logins, and
then eventually removing
support for username-
and password-based logins
so that we can delegate
to trusted sources that
have two-factor auth,
such as GitHub or Google.
And so for our
end users, I guess
we'll see what the
adoption rates are and see
how many providers
we end up having
to go with to make sure we
cover all the small businesses.
But for internal,
since we have G Suite,
and a large percentage
of our resellers do too,
it's likely that we
will choose just Google
to do our identity for that.
So at this point,
I figured I'd ask
if there's any questions
on some of this stuff.
I find this stuff
really exciting.
I find it interesting in
terms of reading about all
this stuff and how these
standards around encryption
work, and then not having
to implement half of them
because Google does it for us.
But I guess there's a
microphone here in the middle,
so if anybody had any questions,
they'd be appreciated.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]